what do you think about this idea of
anonymity of publishing something
anonymously would you ever consider
publishing a paper
you've uh you've been part of i mean the
cardano and
um ecosystem has published a lot of
incredible papers is there ever a value
to publish anonymously well every paper
that goes through the referee process
the authors are ripped off so you don't
actually see the authorship when you
submit to the conference
so that's just best practice but the
question is do you preserve the
anonymity post-conference and actually
um not reveal the author of the paper
it's a detriment
for the deals we make because the whole
premise of working with our company as
an academic is that
you're going to have amazing co-authors
and your work is going to appear in
great conferences great journals and as
a consequence you get tenure
if you publish anonymously you know it's
it's like being like a
doing clearance work in high energy
physics or something like that it's like
after 30 years of this amazing career
working on nuclear weapons
and classified reactors you know you
finished and then you go to apply for a
job and they're like so what have you
done for the last 30 years
stuff where is it on your cv well i
can't really talk about it
okay welcome to community college you
know so you get you get really screwed
if you do that so
there's a misalignment of incentives in
the academic world towards anonymity
um and generally it's only done when
you're doing something very
controversial or there's a
whistleblowing type of a component
it's not typically done for foundational
work and satoshi was really one of the
first things
like if there was a satoshi docks
themselves and i don't think it's
possible anymore
but if he or she did that that's like a
nobel prize in economics
likely you know there's there's a you're
on the shortlist for that
and there's enormous accolades that will
come beyond the monetary incentives of
being able to dox yourself but uh that'd
be cool if they give
a nobel prize in economics to an
anonymous to satoshi nakamoto
it's been proposed and it was 2000. yeah
so yeah i mean
there are a few people in our company
that have done pseudonymous publications
like the if you look at the chimeric
ledger's paper that's a it's not a real
name it's a crazy name
it's uh it's anonymous publication uh
and you know
but that's usually for throwaway work
there is one project we inherited from
an anonymous person which is fascinating
it's called q adidas
and it's basically uh extension of the
qed manifesto from the 90s
and the pseudonym is bill white and i
think it's some anonymous mathematician
but
i can't figure out which one it is but
basically it's a marketplace for
deduction
so it's like a so it's like this magic
machine where you can create incentives
for people to write mathematical proofs
and ethereum prover
and make some money from it so there's
uh there's some cool work
that's there and it's said that bill
stayed anonymous because i think
that could have been easily published
and there was a lot of really cool
things that could be done with q adidas
you